you know the hot breath verse so we are
for comics by comics we appreciate all
y'all hanging out and what we're gonna
do
is bring in our comedy correspondent
chris grulon
and share maybe how this impacts comedy
how this impacts
up and coming comedians and aspiring
comedians and really what we can learn
from this as comedians to really help us
avoid certain pitfalls or to help us
just
learn and grow from this and not just
try to make a funny tweet about it and
move on so
with that being said ladies and
gentlemen
of the hot breath of verse you saw him
when he was talking about
earthquake you saw him when he was
talking about taylor tomlinson you saw
him and he was talking about ali wong
and now he is here
ladies and gentlemen welcome the one and
only
chris grulon ladies and gentlemen give
it up for christmas
[Music]
that conversation got deep
it did yeah
we took it there but you're going to
come in here and lighten it up for us
no i can tell you uh i get i get really
nervous around the cops
i get i get really nervous i get i i
understand exactly what you're feeling
uh uh there was a
an incident here that i had in a small
town here in texas the uh the cop pulled
me over
and i could i was going five miles under
the speed limit i could tell by the way
he was driving that he was gonna pull me
over and when he did
i had my id and my insurance out already
because i was that nervous
and
he didn't even look at it and said i
thought you were going to give me a
reason
and then just drove off
yep
i thought you're going to give me a
reason
yep
and i did not want to find out what the
reason was i was wondering what is it
what a reason
yep i did not want to finish funny
is
joel's look of like just like amazement
like how in the world and my look of
like that feels about right i'm
embarrassed
yeah i do not want to end up somewhere
in the field so yeah i uh
i i had to get the hell out of there but
uh
you never found that weed you were
moving so that's good
i don't know i've never found the weight
i found
that if uh you're very calm
they don't really inspect
i guess being stunned helps yeah if
you're not no i'm just look at me the
white man trying to sweep it under the
rug
like all right that's enough
no it's cool we can make fun of our
trauma joel if you want to no i'm sorry
for sure
can we acknowledge that chris rock was
bombing by the way
i only saw the clip i haven't watched
any uh like the full show or anything
oh my god i mean
i mean when whenever you hear someone
say come on it was a joke and they're a
comedian you're done
you're you're you're losing bro yeah i
mean but also like
but that's the thing i wondered when i
was talking to
joe earlier whether this was a joke that
was already written
was it already written or did he
improvise it in the moment
to your point it could have been bombing
because he saw her straight up and he
looked at her and he was like i'm just
gonna go to a short hair joke because
she's right there right like and she was
wearing green
but
yeah if he knew that she had alopecia
that's a whole different story it's a
whole different thing yeah yeah but but
yeah that's a good point that's a good
point he definitely wasn't like he
wasn't killing him but oh he wasn't
rushing
no one at the oscars is crushing those
jokes are not written for they're not
written by earthquake you know what i'm
saying like
earthquake on a scale oh that slap was
an earthquake i'll tell you that yeah no
no that that slap was definitely an
earthquake holding the hip on that one
yeah yeah really good torque into torque
the other question is what
what venue would allow someone to attack
a comedian and then let him sit back in
their seat for the rest of the show
it's will smith my my dude like yeah
regardless of what like if it could have
been anybody that did it
that was in the public eye
like it's will smith
that
gives you reason to know
how high his status is
in that ecosystem
you don't
shut down will smith regardless of what
he's done
now is that wrong
maybe
right but at the same time that also
gives you like just a perspective
he's kind of untouchable
in some degree
now we'll see if he truly is
right because i think they let it go
because they were so shocked at the
moment but
let's let's point out
in the 25 years that you've known will
smith
he's never done
anything
remotely scandalous
anything like this
not shown one ounce of violence not
showing one ounce of like that's not
true he did slap a photographer
he just slapped a photographer that was
trying to touch him like in a very
inappropriate sexual way
right like
he was defending himself in that moment
right now they blew it up but
he didn't get any trouble because they
were like you don't touch people
you mean like people thought you don't
touch even as a photographer you don't
go up to people or like try to touch a
man's you know yeah yeah
private area but that's my point like
that
that gives you some level of how highly
regarded he is
as an institution will smith is an
institution
he's a business
yeah i mean he got on he got on
instagram and within 12 hours he had
like 12 million followers
which is yeah insane
but is it i one thing people are saying
in the comedy world is that
it
this will now give other people
uh like in a reason if they're offended
to get on stage and attack a comedian
but i mean
i don't know if i believe that because
it's like when kanye went up
with taylor swift and was like beyonce's
video was better like people then didn't
go and start doing that
like
i don't think i don't know if people are
seeing will smith smack chris rock and
being like oh when i'm at the chuckle
hut
in bfe kansas
and this comic
says something i don't agree with that
like coke is better than pepsi i'm gonna
go up there and like you know shank him
i don't i don't see it translating to
like comedy venues
and i hope
i'm right about that i hope like next
week a video doesn't surface but but see
on the flip side of that we are
uh there are states that are open carry
and so
me as a comedian you're not just gonna
walk up on me and think that it's gonna
end
the way chris rock ended someone's going
and someone's going to a hospital it may
be me but i'll definitely attempt
i'll attempt to treat you i promise you
yeah for sure
but
i have the right to defend myself you
can't now i now a lesson from the chris
rock thing is
you can't
words have consequences you cannot just
say whatever
it is and use the
the
curtain of i'm a comedian
because
will smith has been battling this for
two years
uh
he laughed at first but he may have seen
his wife hurt and immediately caught
that trigger of like i need to defend
her right now
and i need to do something about it and
he could have handled it anyway he could
have talked to him backstage
whatever there could have been reports
of him smacking chris rock behind the
scenes and no one would have ever seen
it the fact that this was so public
it
i mean it didn't really damage chris
rock because as a comedian we know that
he's gonna write about it and talk about
it
his sales went through the roof the next
day
[Music]
but
the level of disrespect like
i i i didn't i didn't like it and then
what i didn't
what i found hard was the comedians that
have been abused on stage
reliving that trauma
and
putting those videos out like polly
short put one up where he was actually
smacked or he was punched
on stage um and he's sitting there
saying i'm sorry i didn't mean to i was
just telling you to be quiet because i'm
in my set and the guy took offense to
that and punched him in the face
and um
yeah it's
it's been it's been triggering to a lot
of people it's the same thing with with
the uh
uh
chris brown and rihanna situation
where
it was bringing up the trauma in a lot
of abusive
relationships uh
so i mean it it was will
living his
turmoil but that set off
a huge
avalanche of feelings that other people
were having comedians now don't feel
safe
we already felt that we couldn't say
what we wanted to say on stage because
of political correctness now what if i
say something wrong
that is going to offend somebody that's
going to cause an ordeal
that could cost us our freedom or our
lives
and
i mean i was on stage i was at a show a
couple weeks ago and one of the
comedians saw a girl on the stage in the
crowd and said uh what type of asian are
you and she said i'm puerto rican
that could have turned left quick
and
it could have been a huge
issue
uh luckily everything was diffused but
it's things like that if you're not
aware
of what you're saying
or prepared of what you're saying and
you try to riff and you're not ready to
riff or have
be prepared for the consequences you
could end up putting yourself in a
really tight spot
in the venue in a tight spot
and so it's a bigger ordeal than that i
don't think
now they're the grammys are coming up
that's going to be huge because kanye's
might be in the crowd what is he going
to do
you know what i mean
i think people were
i think people were scared of kanye
before this even happened
he's built up a lot of a lot of brand
equity in that
assumption
yeah about that assumption i mean it's a
good point chris i think there are
consequences
and repercussions of
showing
and
kind of
us being okay with the violence of what
took place in front of our eyes right
like
i i can't imagine
luckily i didn't watch this with my kids
right but i can't imagine how you
explain this to kids
that
like on both sides like it's okay to
defend mom but also
it's not okay to say jokes you know i'm
saying it's like where do you draw that
line of what you just saw
right in terms of what he did to another
person you know i'm saying so i think
there's a lot of
areas of comedians who are going to have
to to your point be careful about what
they say
but i think comedians have always had to
be careful about what they said you mean
i think
there's been you know there's comedians
that
would that
i would say could not say that n word
and then would say the n word and then
get mad that people got mad at them for
saying the n word on stage you're like
what'd you think was going to happen
yeah i'm saying like you know some some
people i think what we are starting to
define is
where's the line
and also understanding as comedians
that you're probably going to cross the
line even when you don't know you've
crossed it
and not everybody is a chappelle
of bill burr
anthony jesselnick or chris rock so
these guys are these guys have have
mastered
how
to do the controversy and bring it back
for sure i've seen some people just
throw themselves out in the deep end and
not have a paddle to come back or a life
raft to come back and they're stuck out
there and then they're stuck the whole
show and now they're making it tough for
everybody else
and so if i'm if i'm on a show with
somebody that's getting attacked
am i supposed to protect the comedian
now you're putting me in a position
because you can't shut your mouth
and so it turns into a bigger ordeal
yeah i mean and i think there's a thing
i i feel like this was a conversation
that was going to happen sooner or later
anyway because
you know i think there's been some
comics that have felt like oh is this
what's happening to comedy but the
reality is this has kind of existed
already
we've known
comics that have been attacked on stage
comics have gotten attacked on stage we
just didn't
the oscars just brought it to in essence
top five biggest stars
that we've got in the world right the
will smith is top five
biggest movie stars of all time
imagine
imagine feeling
what will smith was feeling and
forgetting that you're on one of the
biggest stages in the world
yeah and then just going up and smacking
chris rock like you weren't on live tv
and then yelling yeah and then yelling
and then making everybody else
uncomfortable
yeah that was great like that's part of
but here's the other thing though right
do you also believe that chris
will smith
also believe that
maybe
he could have done worse
do you could have knocked him out even
shown restraint like do you think the
smack even in itself
was kind of just like
that was a warning
not saying it was right
right because he smacked him and went
and sat back down like nothing happened
as if they're like i just needed to do
that and
and that was the crazy part he laughed
smacked him
went back to a seat got angry cried that
night and then went out to party will
smith needs to be checked out
because it would have ruined my night
regardless if i was the one smack for
the one smacking somebody
i would have been so upset i wouldn't
have been able to just relax that that
that was what stood out to me that was
crazy
yeah and the joke it it hit it
it came off as offensive because i think
it was about something she couldn't help
and i think sometimes with roasting it's
like if you roast someone for something
they can't help
they may take it one way versus if it's
a more playful joke which on the surface
gi jane i mean
yeah it's not the best joke ever it
makes a point it makes a jab and then he
was moving on but the fact she has
alopecia
plays into now oh it's this medical
condition she can't control which i
don't know if chris knew or not i i read
that he didn't know
but i doubt he would intentionally be
like oh let's go after jada pink and
smith and plant my flag at the oscars
that she's bald like
i think alopecia yeah there's no i don't
i i think we got to give chris rock some
credit there's no way that that dude
knew that she had alopecia or that that
was a medical condition you got to give
him some credit on on that
because i think he understands the limit
of what can be said there's other jokes
you could have made
but he made a hair joke at the end of
the day it was a hair joke right that we
did not know
based on the condition so you got a good
point joel he had no idea but that's
comedy interpretation
he made a bald joke
but
it felt offensive to her
that's the consequences
tavis aikman said uh if chris wanted to
be malicious then he would have talked
about her infidelity yeah cause there
was a bigger fish the intake
it's a bigger joke like he could have
been like where's august
is august here and then
will smacking him
would have made sense
would have made more sense about
infidelity than like a hair joke that
was more of like a throwaway joke you
know
yeah but i'm curious like as a as like
newer comedians i'm curious does this
make you more hesitant or
like as a comedian how do you react to
this of is there more fear now or what
well i mean i'm i'm more scared to sit
in front of in the front row of a chris
rock [__] show because i don't want
him to make fun of me but
uh
my
my whole thing is if you are writing
jokes
to get shocked
and you're purposely messing with the
crowd then you're gonna get that
reaction whether it whether it be
you getting attacked
or
the least
confrontational
and
if you're not
when i when i write it's all personal so
i did chris rock and will smith jokes
last night but i tied it back to me
being bald
and brought it back to my point of view
it wasn't making fun of her having
alopecia
because that's a condition she can't
control but what's my point of view on
chris rock i saw the all the memes and
uh if he was mad in march wait till
august and all those were coming up but
which were which they were great but
they haven't it's pretty phenomenal
the oscars let's not
get it twisted the oscars
are
entertaining
they put a comedian up front to make fun
of the industry everyone gets tagged in
the oscars you know i'm saying like
ricky gervais went in a couple years ago
on people i mean but i'm sure there's
people that wanted to smack this out of
that dude you mean i mean martin
lawrence i i i was watching martin
lawrence and go to youtube and type in
martin lawrence mclight
and
in that clip martin lawrence is talking
to the crowd he's doing crowd work and
he sees a friend that is dating m.c
light at the time
yeah and he's like i see that you're
dating m.c light i understand that you
have a tattoo i want you to know that i
slept with her before you did and then
chaos
and it was just awesome yeah
i saw that that was from death jam
yeah it wasn't as disrespectful as that
but
uh we're known to push the line but if
you're you're not a martin lawrence
uh
yeah and a lot of these venues don't
have the security you think they have
oh no dude we yeah my my friend steve
brown got attacked on stage a few years
ago and i had him on the podcast
and he like the the cooks from the
kitchen came and broke it up like no one
was helping and the guy had like the mic
stand and he was swinging it at him like
it got it got damaged that was the guy
that was having like a manic episode
right
uh the the guy who attacked him the
audience member yeah i think he's this
guy he's having like a bipolar episode
yeah he was having a
manic bipolar episode during the show
and in turn they the venue blamed it on
the comedian
and i think he was banned for a while
from the comedy club
yeah i think that he was blaming his
communion i think they blamed it on a
comedian because that's the easiest
thing to do it's the easiest thing
because we also live in this world where
we believe that the customer is always
right
and we almost have to take the
customer's view
at hand like yeah i was offended your
comedian said something that triggered
me give me my money back or i'ma sue
whatever it may be and it's much easier
just to say uh you guys messed up here's
the thing
everyone all the way up to the oscars is
gonna have ramifications of this because
someone wants to feel like something
gets done
based on what took place
and i think that's also part of our sort
of litigious society is that we always
feel like somebody has to take blame for
what took place
now who that's going to be is it going
to be will smith is it going to be the
oscars is it going to be the writers is
it going to be the producer but
somebody's going to take it for this
sadly
yeah because then who do you blame huh
how is he allowed to get all the way up
to that stage without security stopping
him at any point
it looked like a bit
yeah because it looked like it
looked like the whole time and then when
he started yelling i was like oh
maybe he wasn't kidding
yeah i think that's the thing right
that's a good point chris
when will smith comes up to you
you don't back away
you don't think you're not seeing will
smith the man
the guy who's protecting his wife you're
seeing will smith the movie star
like
chris rock was just like oh i made
something i made will smith react to a
jada pinkett hair joke
he thought something was going to happen
but eden obviously did not think he was
going to get
his face swiped early
[Music]
and that's
why
everyone around also believe that no one
ever
planned that will smith was gonna smack
somebody in the face but but will smith
would have never done it to anybody else
he wouldn't have smacked earthquake he
wouldn't have smacked steve harvey
because they would have hustled they
would have fought
i think he would i don't think i don't
anyone whoever was the host
i i put it this way i feel like i feel
like if
any man that was up there would have
gotten the business from will smith
but i i mean the other thing is that
what i hated about the whole thing is
the predicament it put all the other
husbands in
like because then every wife looked over
and said would you do that for me
yep no no i wouldn't
because i don't have the lawyer money
that will smith does
i'm not smacking chris rock
but it is interesting to see
i think with people posting crowd work
clips every day and you see someone like
andrew schultz
getting a like getting away with saying
seemingly offensive things
but he says it in a way you know that
he's developed over 20 years of doing
stand-up and if even someone like chris
rock
can have a misstep like this it's like
for younger comics it's like
yes you may want to
have a voice and say certain messages
and shift culture but you know one bite
at a time just get good at stand up and
then kind of learn the rules and then
break them like it's this is a long play
here and if someone like chris rock
can trip up like this jen if you're a
newer comic it's like
you know
steady as she goes
i i don't i don't consider what chris
rock did a slip up though
it was just a bad joke
but i mean and then he has ramifications
from it so like any comic at any level
can you know catch this l at any moment
but i mean it was a it was a
it was a roast joke
it wasn't
severely offensive it was he he he tied
buzzka with green
and thought army
but here's the thing chris
regardless of what you believe
the level of joke structure and the
level of offense is
it doesn't matter
it's that she was offended by it no
matter what it was right was it a strong
joke from the comedian standpoint you'd
be like ah that's pretty good
association you got the greens
but it didn't matter
she was offended
and that's truly what it comes down to
this was
this was a man protecting his wife
yeah like it was a man protecting the
honor of his wife right but was it was
it protecting her
after being caught laughing at the joke
did he feel like oh yeah
i think i think the laughter at the joke
is conditioning he laughs at all jokes
he's the biggest movie star in the world
he's been at this place before he's been
at the oscars he laughs at everything
because everyone's either gonna make fun
of him he's just gonna laugh he's not
gonna be like oh that's a terrible joke
he's will smith he's gonna act the part
of will smith right but he saw his
wife's reaction
and that's what triggered him like in
that moment like i've laughed at a joke
looked at my wife and be like i'ma stop
laughing
i think we've all done it i i mean it's
not through we've all i believe we've
all done it
that we looked at our wives and we like
all right let me stop laughing at that
at that joke i kind of might have
enjoyed that too much
you know i'm saying but yeah but if
you're not a certain fan of of jada you
would never know that she had alopecia
oh of course not of course you know
yeah no no i i i think tons of people
didn't know
tons of people didn't know right but
that's the thing about the internet
right is that we also assume that
because one person knows that everyone
else should know but i don't think they
sat
chris rock down be like yo
she had alopecia let's stay away from
ball jokes
no one knows that
the i doubt that even the producers
would have thought that that would be a
thing
that's the thing i really want to know
is whether the producers were okay with
that joke whether they greenlighted that
joke because that felt like just a joke
that they're like we could only talk
about this part we can't talk about what
we talked about earlier the infidelity
we can talk about
the both part
right yeah yeah that's interesting fresh
out of bed said one of the hardest parts
of being a new comedian is not knowing
what you can and can't say
that's why you stick to the stuff that's
true to you
max
chris is preaching that gospel he's
preaching that hot breath gospel
yep you talk about the things that are
true to your life and you won't have
that problem
bars
[Music]
that's bars fam that's bars
big facts
yeah yeah one of the one of the things
that comedians try to do when they first
come out is talk
about a shock stuff
sexual and
their penis sizes and sleeping with
women
it's natural it's the first thing that
you're like
that you know that like when you were
talking with your own friends in your
own circle it's what got laughs
penis jokes sex jokes dirty stuff gets
laughs like easily
so as a starting comedian you think
let me talk about this because i know
that that's what get laughs until you
learn the structure
of other things and be like okay
let's we can be better than this
yeah and and
um
yeah it's it's it's i don't know the way
i saw it was it
everybody's worried about comedians
having a target on their back i don't i
don't see it that way because we already
had the target like you said exactly
there's been comedians attacked before
yeah
i've just never seen it at this scale
and the lesson is if you're gonna roast
somebody make sure you're at a roast
don't start roasting the crowd because
then
you're
what what you're doing is
that's what you're doing
yeah because what you're doing is
pointing someone out and making the
crowd laugh at that one person
now you're being mean that's a bully
what yeah
what i try to do is in general talk
about everybody
and that's a good point but the oscars
is a roast
yeah
the oscars
when did it turn to that
oh it's always been that the oscars
always make fun of the actors
that's the point they make fun of the
actors that make fun of the movies like
amy schumer made fun of uh leonardo
dicaprio he was just i think she said
something like oh leonardo is getting
like the lifetime award
uh
so he can help the next generation of
his girlfriend like he was like
basically that he's like an
environmentalist so he can save the
world for his girlfriends like yeah yeah
it's it's meant to be a roast
the roast is what we actually watch the
oscars for we're not watching it for the
movies
that's the problem that's what happened
when they didn't have hosts before
is that they were suffering and from an
entertainment value perspective of not
having anything entertaining and just
having hollywood go up on stage receive
an award people are like i'm not tuning
into this i could just read who won
people tune in to see the comics
comedians
hosting the oscars and the grammys have
always done better from an entertainment
perspective
because they're funny steve harvey
hosting all those shows is there because
he's a comedian because he's hilarious
steve harvey taking over family feud is
one of the number one shows because
steve harvey is funny
he can hold anything right him hosting
miss america he's funny
i think the key is when does
entertainment
go too far right yeah and i think and
that's what i'm saying i don't think
that
i don't think that that joke was too far
and now it triggered her
and then triggered him
but how would he know that as the
comedian making such a
uh a joke on
her
buzz cut
and
green
you know what i mean like yeah and on
stage he was just trying to be quick he
was making fun of
it i i it didn't warrant the smack
that's all i'm saying it
oh nothing warranted the smack yeah no
definitely nothing but that is a lesson
i think for comedians is that you know
your words are powerful and your words
do matter and something you think is a
throwaway
may really trigger someone you just
never know what saying
a certain phrase talking about a certain
topic may trigger someone in any way so
it's
yes your words are powerful enough to
provoke laughter but they can also
provoke anger
and jealousy and like resentment or
whatever you know so it's it's really
being mindful like what you say actually
does matter and that's why we're so
thoughtful
at hot breath of you know writing
well-written jokes that come from a
personal place and really giving a lot
of thought to what you're saying
because you know it it really does
matter and this is an example of oh it
was a hair joke and now look at where we
are so like don't take any joke for
granted
yeah but i also think we also have to
remember roast roasting
also does the opposite effect as well
um
hannibal burris roasting bill cosby
was the reason bill cosby is now in jail
no let's not get it twisted him bringing
it up in that space
making fun of him
brought light to the situation which
became the trigger points of how
bad we knew what bill cosby was doing is
right
comedy just brings things to life
that's what we do as comedians we're
bringing things to life
first of all i haven't heard a gi jane
reference in so long i'm sure there were
people that were just saying that was
the other thing yeah
[Laughter]
how old is that i had to think about it
like the demi moore movie is that what
we're talking about that's great
that's that's what it is right but
that's the thing it's like i know
comedians that saw that there was like a
gi joe reference that's lame
thinking that they just changed it to
gig it's like no that's an actual movie
with someone with short hair but it's
like you almost have to be of a certain
age to actually get that joke either
right so to your point it may not have
been a great joke he was
bombing he was just pulling out he could
have been just pulling out like just
things that he saw he was trying stuff
to try to figure something out because
the set wasn't going great
i mean the the when he said it's a joke
i was like oh you're dying up here
uh as a comedian you should never tell
anybody you're telling them jokes
you're excited you just got smacked
though
so you gotta say it's a joke
[Laughter]
yeah well i mean before you saw will
coming up he's like oh come on ah like
he was getting squirmish and then then
will did that wwe walk
towards him that was a wwe walk for sure
yeah he really wouldn't he really
yeah that was definitely a vince mcmahon
walk up on that
on that stage
[Music]
and he like walked back he had his hand
on his vest like all like puffed up then
he used his vest like a gentleman yeah
he was all adapted up for that beat down
oh man
what what can comics like what can
comics take away from this like what can
what can we learn from the end of the
day to know that there are consequences
and repercussions for everything that
you say
right and to chris's point like
if there you must know that there's
consequences of repercussions
therefore
if you're talking about things on stage
it to the stuff if possible
that only you would know about
yes you can make a reference to
um
what's going on in the zeitgeist or
what's going on in the news or whatever
but make it about you because no one can
take that away from you
yeah and and uh on
on the flip side to that when when
you're writing a joke
if you're uncomfortable with the wording
of it give it to someone else for a
second set of eyes
what i what i did i was writing a joke
um
that
had that talked about transgender people
and i didn't want to offend transgender
people
um so i sent it to a friend of mine who
is transgender and i said hey if i were
to say this on stage would you be
offended they said yes turns out the
joke
had nothing to do with the transgender
people i could switch the whole joke
around and just change that part but i
made sure that before i even said it on
stage this
was cleared
to not offend anybody because that's the
last thing i want to do i want to make
you laugh not uncomfortable on stage
yeah
yeah i totally agree with both of those
things i think it is huge
i'm hoping young comics see it and
realize oh man what i say does have
power and i should give some thought to
it
and you know the hot breath community
exists for comics to help comics so i'm
hoping maybe people hearing this or
watching this
see it as an opportunity
to be more thoughtful about the comedy
they're putting out there because
a lot of the
controversial comedy is popular i mean i
i can't help but use andrew schultz as
the example but he's killing it and he
says a lot of controversial things but
this is a guy who has built his comedy
over decades to get to this point so yes
he's someone to watch but not
necessarily want to be andrew schultz
2.0 but be you you know the only thing
no one can steal are about you so do you
and create your own version
of what you want to be and see a success
and not try to like imitate certain
people but to your to your point on
andrew schultz
he built his fan base
so his fans know what to expect when
they go to his show so he's comfortable
to do that because they already know
what it's about he doesn't hide that
now if it were
like hanging with mr cooper
and you're expecting those type of jokes
when you see mark curry
and you're in for a surprise that that's
different
yeah but andrew schultz has built his
fan base and he's a very smart guy
yeah he's he he he knows how to pull
himself in and out of these situations
that bring the crowd in and get the
laughter like i saw one where he was
talking about silver bracelets
and he went into this huge history about
the silver bracelet
uh
in the uh indian culture
and
then at the end of the joke was now that
indian bracelet it was meant to protect
you from swords hitting your forearm
and now it protects the steering wheel
of the uber you drive
and
it was it was a funny joke
and the guy he was talking to
laughed and everybody laughed with him
but they knew what to expect because
this is
this is his type of audience
but you can't go to an open mic and
think that that's what you're going to
say because you don't know who you're
getting in that crowd they're not your
fans
yeah that's a that's a
that's a good point um
yeah and i think
any comedian should
i think i forget who said it it might
have been beth stelling
on the podcast
she said it along on the first one that
you did joel that your words have
consequences
like
as jokes your jokes represent you so
even as you're saying the wild stuff
know that that's the stuff that
represents who you are
as a comic
and you never know who's in the audience
you never know who's like you know
watching to know that now that has be
that joke that you said about
you know 9 11 that was not good
is now associated with you yeah and
people in the scene are just like yeah
that's the 9 11 joke guy it's not very
good but that's the guy
like that has repercussions
yeah and and
as a as a new comedian you you you get
really excited about wanting to put all
your videos out on youtube and and all
on social media and
they'll be there forever
but you'll evolve as a comedian but
they'll always reference you to
that bad joke you did about
gay people or lesbian people as you were
starting up
trying to get your work structure so you
got to be very mindful of even the stuff
you put out
for sure
yeah you just i i don't know i'm very i
if i do a joke that's topical like the
chris rock and will smith i make sure
that it's tied to me somehow
so that i'm not embarrassed when someone
i put one out and i got a bunch of booze
this morning
uh from some troll but nice
that joe can come back
five years from now i'll be fine with it
yeah that's what you gotta ask yourself
if you're gonna put this up are you
gonna be okay with it
five years from now yeah yeah that's
exactly what mr truth said there's
always going to be someone who doesn't
like what you have to say but can you
honestly respect
yourself with what you're saying and are
you prepared for the possible
consequences
for what you say and i think that's
that's that's what it comes down to is
are you prepared
to go to bat for these words
i don't think chris rock would have gone
to bat for those words it would be like
i that's
not my best yeah but
that's what happens i mean but that's
kind of what happens you know i think
and also like
as much as we're talking about this we
just are watching like
two very privileged people
have a public fight
and it's like at the end of the day
they're gonna be all right like they
they literally all made more money than
we have probably made in our lifetimes
in the last 24 hours
they're going to be fine we're going to
put it that way
i did like the fact that when he
mentioned g.i jane
no one batted an eye that it couldn't be
jada
because she's so ripped
everybody was no one i mean she could
actually play that part
for sure if if someone really wants to
take advantage of this a gi jane 2 would
be dope for real for real star let's
talk about it now that's what i was more
offended by is is this really happening
that'd be dope
spin-off or maybe a buddy cop with will
smith and chris rock
i smell a netflix original adam sandler
can produce it
dude they'd make so much money if they
did that
oh everybody would watch it everybody
would want and they would have to
reference it they would have to
reference the smack
yeah yeah
yeah with august ospina playing a part
yeah yeah that's probably not gonna
happen
he does the soundtrack
yeah bobby had said that earlier they're
gonna have a comedy duo film
well good yeah i think we got some good
takeaways for uh comics there
and um
yeah that was good
i feel good about that
yeah
yeah but uh i think i think and this is
another another lesson to comedians is
things like this are topical
so they only have a shelf life
three days now yeah you know who's three
days excited about this kanye west he
was just like thank you the pressure is
off of me for a little bit
or is it and now we want to see him top
the smack
what are you gonna do with the grammys
because they didn't ban him from
showing up
they banned him from performing
yeah
and he's known to rush the stage so
we shall see but yeah this was
definitely topical we wanted to get out
which is why we didn't do a comedy
special review
uh but the show's evolving you know
we're figuring it out but we appreciate
everyone that hangs out and enjoys these
we've been getting a lot of great
feedback on our comedy special feedback
so now we're like oh wonder if us
talking about topics would be full of
people you know
i'd be fascinated to know what jeff
foxworthy thinks of a smack oh my god oh
i think he didn't mention i think he did
say something i know tim allen did
really
yep i can't imagine jeff saying
something
somebody asked him out how long
how long is too long for topics like
this well will smith apologized
so it's over
right oh
i mean to some degree it kind of is
and we've been talking about it at
nauseam since it happened as comedians
with the memes the
after a while things become over
saturated
and there's no other angle you can take
on this joke
for sure
oh boy
maggaconservatives.com
[Laughter]
oh it has tim allen's tweet sorry guys
this was not my home page i promise
if it's maggie
no one patted an eye when it said it was
saved on your screen though
they saw that tab they saw the maga tab
all right i can see where it is
oh yeah uh tim allen said it's not okay
to come on stage and hit a dude because
you don't like the humor
it's not okay at a comedy club concert
hall or hosting some cheese ball awards
show
chris rock is a stand-up comedian
oh
uh stand-up comedian and a stand-up guy
who carried on i think i would have run
okay
yeah so they that's not surprising
yeah that's random
coming from tim allen maybe he has a
special coming out or something
and tim allen's been to jail by the way
he's been a lot of places
yeah he's done prison time stuff to say
he would run
well thanks for doing this chris i think
that was a good breakdown for comics out
there you brought in a good perspective
yeah so the takeaway is if you're
bombing
just say good night
don't keep don't don't don't keep going
keep digging don't say what else what
else don't say what what do you all want
to talk about don't say i'll i'll leave
with this one justly yeah i've seen so
many comics flail
yeah yeah and be like oh i'll get them
with this next one and they run the
light by four minutes and bomb that
whole time they're like nah this next
one
it's gonna get yeah i saw this i saw
this one guy run the light or he he got
the light he had a minute left and he's
like
so i was at my divorce this morning and
i was like oh god this is gonna be bad
and then he went on and and so i found a
trick on how to to
blow the light is close your eyes that
way you don't see it
cause that's what
hey that's what he did and it was three
minutes past they should have been
playing the music on chris rock they're
like just get out of there rock get out
of there champ
i need to get a will will smith
impersonator to come down
at least he caught will smith after
richard not after
the muhammad ali movie
[Music]
yeah that would have been a beefy smack
big facts
it would have been a totally different
snack
nice
well all right well let's land this
plane i guess we can do some uh
joke some joke feedback
yeah so are we doing the jeffy one next
week
um
[Music]
yeah unless kanye does something yeah is
it this weekend the grammys
i think it's this weekend oh i don't
know yeah
yeah we can do jeff next weekend
unless
have you did you guys watch it
i haven't seen it yet
i haven't seen it yet i was going to see
it last night
um or yesterday i've been uh
i've been getting comedians sending me
their videos to break down
you're gonna have to start a
a review business here
yeah yeah uh so i've been busy with that
but
dang what a nice guy
yeah it's been cool
good for you look at us we gotta we're
gonna own little like um not little i
mean our own celebrity here we got a hot
breath fluencer
a breath influencer
we're all influencers hey at this
sweater i won because of hot breath
is that eddie bauer
let's go
let's go this is eddie bauer too champ
yep this is that sweater i want to in
that contest you had
that's sick got that eddie my my wife
hates it
[Laughter]
perfect
it's on the internet forever
perfect i'm glad it could live on this
episode forever yeah
my wife hates i wore it because we were
comedians are at war
that's why i wore it today
i like it i i don't know how we didn't
connect the dots there i don't know
also i wanted to camouflage with the
background in case will smith charges my
stage
it's like your wife is going to charge
you with that uh wearing that in public
yeah g.i bruion over there
so i'll see you guys next week dave
absolutely chris looking forward to it
buddy
all right